[Music]
[Applause]
Ross Tucker Westwood One CBS sports
analyst and former offensive lineman the
Ross Tucker football podcast is a must
listen and you can find him on social
media as uh at not ass I think I said
ass Ross Tucker NFL that might work too
yeah no problem Dan how are you man good
to see you okay give me your head
scratcher last night
oh
um I got a couple of them I guess I
think it's a little bit of a head
scratcher that the Houston Texans gave
up as much as they did for Will Anderson
and I think what happened look I love
will Anderson Dan but that's a lot I
mean the third the 33rd pick is
essentially another first round pick
next year's first round pick we usually
don't see teams give up that much for a
defensive player I mean if it's it's one
thing for a starting quarterback or a
franchise quarterback but for a
defensive player and and my read on that
Dan is always the same when I see GM's
like Joe Douglas for the Jets or Nick
casario for the Texans starting to give
up future ones future draft picks like
they're doing it usually means they
think there's a chance they're on the
hot seat and they need to win that year
and I don't really blame them right who
cares about next year's first round pick
if you're fired if you're not there
anymore but the more teams give future
picks the more I think that general
manager wonders what kind of footing
he's on for that franchise but you have
a coach D'Amico Ryan's who's just
starting there Nick casario has been
there as the GM so you do you have you
know conflicting interest there of you
got a coach who just started with a
six-year deal and does he want to give
up draft Capital next year for a line
you know an edge rusher here
it's a terrific Point Dan which is why
most good organizations try to have
those two positions aligned because now
you've got your two decision makers and
they'll say all the right things that
they're on the same page but they're not
on the same timeline if you're not on
the same timeline you can't possibly be
on the same page because you have
different interests in mind when you're
making some of these decisions I think
we saw that from the Houston Texans last
night but also people have to remember
Carolina traded up to get Bryce young if
that doesn't work out you're really in
trouble because you failed with the
number one overall pick and you had to
trade up with the Bears to get that
number one pick
well and the thing I keep thinking about
is think about the Houston Texans I
think everybody believes they wanted
Bryce young and would have rather had
Bryce young and that that's all time bad
process by the Texans to make it pretty
clear they were going to fire Lovey
Smith before the last game last year and
then lovey goes out and wins and gives
them a uh a parting gift I mean that
that could be franchise altering yeah
there weren't a lot of questions about
Bryce young other than the size there
were people that were very concerned
about CJ Stroud I mean that that one
loss or in this case win by the Texans
could be franchise altering for a decade
or more
I thought the Jets failed Aaron Rodgers
last night because it's already a top
five defense
I would you're you're not winning by
your defense in the NFL it helps to have
somebody who can stop somebody when you
need a stop
this is the the new NFL or this is the
way it is I would have gone after a
tight end or one of those wide receivers
they got scooped because it felt like
they were going to take an offensive
lineman but uh give me the strategy
behind what the Jets did with Aaron
Rodgers yeah Dan Jets fans are mad at me
but honestly this is why the Jets are
the Jets I mean there's a lot of bad
here a lot of bad here first of all
I thought they had way too much leverage
to give up what they did for Aaron
Rodgers are you kidding me I mean a one
and a two and you flip picks which they
didn't think was a big deal it was a big
deal last night yes that they did that I
think for a for 60 million dollars for a
guy that might only play one year all
that for the right to pay Roger and
people and the Jets fan always going to
restructure he's not taking less bro I
promise you he's not taking less
restructure is for cat purposes it's not
less money and so here's the other thing
Dan
there are certain organizations and you
know this they just have loose lips man
every single mock draft had the Jets
taking Broderick Jones at 13. every mock
draft even with mock drafts where
scaronski was still available or Darnell
Wright was still available everybody and
their brother knew the Jets won an
offensive lineman and knew they liked
Broderick Jones you can't have it that
way Dan you can't first of all you can't
have that obvious opposition of need
secondly you can't let everybody know
who you want because then what the
Steelers do dealers went from 17 to 14
with the Patriots they only had to give
up a fourth round pick they went right
in front of the Jets and took the guy
the Jets were going to take there's zero
percent chance the Jets were going to
take Will McDonald the fourth over
Broderick Jones they got scooped they
got beat by the Patriots they got beat
by the Steelers they got beat by the
Packers in that scenario they should
have traded down after that if you're
not going to get the guy that you want
there trade down and then maybe somebody
fall calls to you but I still I I would
have grabbed another wide receiver or I
would have grabbed a tight end here get
somebody who helps you right now and and
you still have needs with your offense I
I just
it they they didn't they didn't have a
good night or or even or even Dan think
about like the Jaguars right they lost
Juwan Taylor in uh free agency cam
Robinson suspended the Jags traded down
twice in the 20s and still got Anton
Harrison the offensive tackle from
Oklahoma so the Jets could have done
something like that now in Ferris to the
Jets you know it takes two to tango
somebody has to want to move up right
like you can't just trade down just to
trade down somebody has to want to move
up to 15. but I I just thought it was
really poor process by the New York Jets
and now I think they're short a guy at
least one guy up front yeah and I know
they have cap space you know this has
been mentioned to me that they can go
out and get you know somebody but they
could have gotten somebody last night
we're talking to Ross Tucker Westwood
won CBS NFL and college football analyst
did the Cowboys get scooped last night
yeah I feel like this happens to them
all the time I mean you know just the
fact I can't decide whether
they were really discussing who they
were going to take that long because
should you ever be in a point where you
have to take the full 10 minutes and
like they showed McCarthy and Jerry
Jones with like 45 seconds left still
talking and then they put it in and
Stephen Jones it looks around he's like
okay it's time to clap guys it's time to
do the fake Clap the fake clap is
hilarious to me like can you can we
organize this a little bit more can we
have somebody else initiate it the fake
cloud like like they're thrilled that
they got mozzie Smith like that's the
guy they want I think everybody believes
they want adult and Kincaid they wanted
a tight end to be able to stretch the
middle of the field for Dak Prescott
they need to replace Dalton Schultz but
the Cowboys are another I'm actually
amazed that the Cowboys draft as well as
they do
considering how often it seems like
people have a pretty good feel for what
they're going to do I mean sometimes
they just get lucky I mean the Micah
Parsons thing they wanted a corner at
10. you know a couple years ago but the
court JC horn and certain went off the
board so the Eagles moved up for Devante
Smith the Cowboys kind of locked into
Micah Parsons the the Dak Prescott year
the Cowboys wanted Paxton Lynch in the
first round even at the top of the
fourth round they wanted Connor Cook I
mean the best picks the Cowboys make are
when they don't get the guy they
actually want yeah it's unbelievable I
know I know but I I there's no way now I
know that they had problems stopping the
run but if you're Jerry Jones you love
to have shiny toys and he would love to
have you know if it's a tight end or a
wide receiver whatever it is I thought
you know
they they I think they were caught it
was like oh my God wait Buffalo did what
and now all of a sudden we'll do good I
don't know who are we taking I don't
know whoever we take let's applaud and
act like it's the guy that we really
wanted and you know what Dan this is a
so because some organizations are better
at this than others
it's never good if you go into the draft
with a glaring need like the Jets had on
the offensive line let the Cowboys have
a tight end you gotta have somebody that
is good enough at that position you have
to have a baseline starter at that
position so it's not like you're
telegraphing what position you would
like to select a player now look there's
a lot of good tight ends this year so
I'm sure the Cowboys will take one in
the second or third round or whatever
but it's still not good to have that
huge hole back in the day teams always
have like one starter left oh we'll just
take a guy in the first round you can't
do that anymore
poll question is who goes uh first today
or before the other one uh will Levis or
Hendon hooker
that is a good one
um I would not be surprised if it's
Hendon hooker you know I I felt bad for
will Levis last night but I'm not that
surprised I mean Dan we did a live mock
draft like a week ago on my YouTube page
and will Levis didn't get drafted I mean
there was only three teams that were
definitely going to take a quarterback
and as you went through it you knew
Bryce young was one okay so this is what
I said Dan I I compared will Levis to
Kmart okay and here's why right if you
wanted a polished pocket passer you're
not taking Levis you're gonna take CJ
Stroud if you wanted like the high
upside the potential the arm and the
speed and whatever you could take
Anthony Richardson I felt like will
Levis was stuck in the middle which is
kind of where Kmart was right like my
dad's a sales guy he told me Russ if you
want the least expensive thing you go to
Walmart if you want something a little
bit nicer you go to Target or maybe
Tarjay Dan as you call it Target but
that's why Kmart went out of business
you don't want to be in the middle in
life will Levis got stuck in the middle
and that's why he dropped precipitously
explain to me the Colts going all in on
Anthony Richardson with number four and
then saying hey don't expect him to be
Superman right away
well that this is all about Shane
steichen and you know I do the Eagles
preseason games on TV heck I'm here in
Philadelphia right now doing the draft
for them Shane steich in the last two
years had Jalen hurts and I really think
Dan talking with these guys once you
have a quarterback that's a big time
running threat as a play caller and play
designer it is so hard to go back you
know what I mean it's like it's like
once you know how much easier that makes
things once you see the world that that
opens up man it's hard to go back and I
think steiken feels like he has the
template with Hertz which is maybe in
year one you settle Richardson in the
first few games you play minshu Then
when Richardson comes in maybe it's a
heavy ground-based attack like the
eagles were in 2021 but you have the
belief that you can develop him if he's
the right kind of kid as a pastor which
is obviously exactly what the Eagles did
with Hertz last year Shane in has the
template to see how he's going to
develop Anthony Richardson because he
just did it with her over the last two
years and the Eagles Eagles stole the
night I think you know that it's
unbelievable I mean yeah and people then
you know oh you work for them so you're
biased what do you want me to say I mean
they got arguably the best player in the
draft at number nine and none of us
really know the off the field stuff I
know this much he reminds me a lot of
Fletcher Cox in his prime so he can just
follow Fletcher Cox around plus his two
of his mentors two of his older buddies
from Georgia nicobe Dean and Jordan
Davis they just took last year and Nolan
Smith is a crazy High character guy so
he's got three teammates that can keep
him on the right path and then the Nolan
Smith one Dan is interesting to me I
know he tore his Peck but it's bizarre
that he was still there at 30. I don't
know what the knock is I think he's not
a scheme fit for some people as an edge
guy at 62238 but a lot of people thought
the Eagles would take him at 10. I was
floored that he was still available at
30. they got arguably a top three pick
and a top 10 pick at 9 and 30. Before I
Let You Go Lamar Jackson's deal
did the Ravens do the right thing
the Ravens absolutely did the right
thing and Lamar finally did the right
thing you know the Ravenswood the Ravens
essentially offered him this deal last
year Dan I mean they offered him the
Jalen hurts deal before the 2022 season
so I'm thrilled it worked out for Lamar
he saves money on an agent but he took
on all that injury risk Dan the whole
city I mean what if he tore his Patel
attendant like what what if he tore Aqua
a quad like he took on all that injury
risk to get
10 million dollars more I mean instead
of 250 million he gets 260. he didn't
even get more guaranteed I mean he gets
two million dollars more per year it was
not a great process for Lamar but who
cares now all's well that ends well and
you know me Dan as a former player all I
want is for every guy to maximize the
Financial Security they can get for
their families from their gift I talked
to teammates of his that were so scared
he was never going to be able to cash in
this lottery ticket that he had earned
he gets the money it's 185 million
dollars guaranteed nobody with the last
name Jackson at least in Lamar's family
will ever have to worry about money
again it's awesome good to talk to you
have a good weekend thanks for joining
us absolutely you as well Dan thanks for
having me that's Ross Tucker joining us
from Philadelphia Westwood won CBS
Sports NFL and college football analyst
and the host of the Ross Tucker football
podcast